one of the most obvious but in practice
very hardest things to ask a partner
even one we name in our will and whose
life is entirely entwined with ours is
do you still love me there would be so
many reasons why they might not do so
anymore we might have driven them to the
limit with our admittedly at points
really rather challenging behavior we're
not getting any younger there are a lot
of other people especially at work and
in the invisible parts of their life who
would have great things to offer them
it's hard to trust anyone given what can
happen furthermore the signs aren't
necessarily very good at the moment they
do spend a lot of time on their phones
they are a bit distracted their thoughts
do seem elsewhere we can powerfully long
for reassurance and at the same time
what we would need to get this
reassurance presents terrors all of its
own it would mean revealing the extent
of our vulnerability and of the scale of
their power to hurt us
it would mean having to admit how much
of our life is in their hands and how
deeply we depend on their good opinion
of us for our psychological survival
sometimes the cost can feel just too
high especially if we grew up in
families where we got little reassurance
that another person would understand our
needs it seems better not to ask too
directly at the same time that
disengaged manner is unbearable as well
in circumstances we may find ourselves
carrying out one of the strangest
manoeuvres witnessed in relationships we
may seek to get their attention
accompanied by their anger as opposed to
their attention accompanied by their
love we choose to pay the lower price of
seeking signs that they remember we
exist as an alternative to the formal
arduous rejection risky task of securing
proof that they still love us so we wait
until they're quite tired and fed up and
then launch a volley of a qz
you never do much around the house your
job doesn't pay enough you've become
pretty dull lately or at a dinner with
friends we loudly tell a story about
something that happened during their
parents messy divorce what we're really
trying to say is I love you so much I
rely on you to give a sense to my life
but instead we manage to work them up
into a rage and ensure that they will
say brutal things to us of course their
mind is now fully trained on us but with
a horrible irony it's far from the kind
of attention
we were really seeking we who crave
their kindness their enthusiasm their
warmth their compassion that tenderness
and their constructive intelligence to
engage with our needs are on the
receiving end of their very
understandable frustration
disappointment wounded pride and self
protective anger we should when we can
have the courage of our longings we
should build relationships where it's
natural and therefore not too
frightening to seek and receive on a
regular basis basic reassurance that yes
we are wanted
we should make friends with our own
extreme dependence and not see it as a
sign of either shame or evil furthermore
when we next find ourselves on the
receiving end of some utterly unfair
accusations or aggression from our
partner we should bear in mind that
they've probably not turned monstrous
they're simply trying to secure a
reminder that we care for them in the
only way they know how by driving us mad
our relationship reboots cards inspire
conversations that can help to rekindle
love between you and your partner
you